the original rin-tin-tin
was born on a battlefield in France in
1918 in the middle of World War one he
was found as a few day old puppy by a
young American GI named Lee Duncan who
had grown up living a very lonely life
and finding the truest companionship and
affection that he did ever find with
dogs
so in the middle of the war and this was
in the really brutal moment in the war
for him to find a litter of newborn
puppies struck him as nothing short of
miraculous and he felt that his whole
life changed at that very moment and in
fact it did Lee loved saying there will
always be a rin-tin-tin
and there was something about the way he
conducted his life that made it clear
that he believed that there was
something immortal about the dog and
what's interesting is that here we are
nearly a hundred years later still
talking about rin-ten-ten which to me
suggests that Lee was right that even
though this was partly a crazy notion
that a dog could live forever in fact he
has lived forever and the idea of that
pure hero dog has indeed lived forever
and I think we can assume it always will
he was both stronger and faster and
better and smarter but he was also
perfectly willing to chase a ball with
you and to snuggle up with you at the
end of a day so he was an unusual kind
of superhero a lot of what compelled me
to write the book was suddenly real
even though I thought rin-tin-tin was
merely a 50s television character I
discovered and was complete news to me
that he had had a just as illustrious
career or perhaps even more illustrious
career in silent film he made 27 silent
films they were shown all over the world
and that fact alone was astonishing to
me and it made me realize that very
likely my grandparents who were born in
Hungary and lived there until their 20s
had probably seen rin-tin-tin films when
they were growing up and the idea that
this figure could cut through
generations and worlds fascinated me and
it made me really want to write the the
story of that journey however you define
what it means to be an actor this dog
was it in addition to that though he had
something else which was that ability to
project an emotion that completely
enchanted people and made them fall in
love with him and that is what being a
star is I think so enjoy the movie and
thanks again for coming tonight